si la tour eiffel a résisté à la tempête
d'hier ce n'est pas le cas des trois
mille cinq cents arbres endommagés ou
déracinés dans les jardins comme ici au
champ de mars dans les cimetières et le
long des rues toute la journée
2500 employés des services municipaux
ont dégagé des centaines d'arbres faut
rétablir la circulation
la priorité a été donnée aux jardins du
trocadéro au champ-de-mars et aux champs
elysées en prévision des célébrations de
l'an 2000 mais des plus gros dégâts ont
été constatés dans les bois de boulogne
et de vincennes où 140 mille arbres ont
été endommagées soit près de la moitié
l'adjointe au maire de paris françoise
de panafieu n'hésite pas à parler d'un
désastre écologique
il faudra attendre trois ans pour
déblayer entièrement les bois et des
décennies pour reconstituer le
patrimoine vert par précaution car
désabre risque encore de s'effondrer
tous les jardins de la capitale ont été
fermées au public et dans les cimetières
seuls les inhumations ont été autorisés